أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذا هل نتوقع أن يهدأ هذا الاتجاه
للمضي قدمًا
هذا هو مليار سؤال حقيقي أعني
أه تعرف ما فعلناه هو أننا
ألقينا نظرة  نسب القدرة على تحمل التكاليف ، لذا
بالنظر إلى دخل الأسرة إلى
أسعار المساكن ، فبالنظر إلى أن الأمور جاهزة لشراء
شقة في الرياض ، فأنت بحاجة إلى حوالي ثلاثة
أو أربعة أضعاف دخلك السنوي لشراء
فيلا ، فأنت بحاجة إلى حوالي ثمانية أضعاف
دخلك السنوي في جدة ، أي حوالي 13
ضعف دخلك السنوي.  لشراء فيلا على
مستوى العالم ، فإن المتوسط ​​المقبول لما
يعتبر ميسور التكلفة عادة ما يكون من أربعة إلى
ستة أضعاف دخلك ، لذلك نحن أعلى من
تلك المستويات بالنسبة للفيلات ، فنحن نقترب من هذا
المستوى للشقق ، وإذا نظرنا
إلى آخر ذروة للسوق ، فهذا
كان للسوق دورتين ، نحن الآن في الدورة
الثانية ، كانت آخر ذروة كانت نسب
الشقق حوالي أربع قبل أن يبلغ
السوق ذروته ، لذا فإن البيانات الآن
تشير إلى أننا قد
نكون على وشك الوصول إلى ذروة جديدة أو  على
الأقل  هضبة جديدة حيث
استقرت الأسعار لفترة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]